we look at your credits on imdb antoine
we see that you've worked on a number of
projects
how are you working
with the screenwriting are you taking
the idea and
choosing a screenwriter so what i do is
i have a writing team
um whenever you eugene walker john
torres
uh grade de casa so what i do i come
with the idea
and i probably write the treatment
whatever but i pretty much come with the
idea and i'll hire the writers to write
it for me because um like during covet
me and my right team got together and we
wrote over 50 trips
because a lot of times if you're a
writer you want to make 100 drafts you
want to do this i'm directing it so i
don't need 100 drafts i need maybe two
or three then i'm good to go i'm gonna
change what i'm on set so um i'm able to
knock all those trips out and um yeah so
all the ideas are my ideas and then i
get the rights to come on board help me
flesh it out
and where are you meeting these
screenwriters with my friends some of
them are friends some with actors uh one
of my writers eugene walker he will my
partners he was a few of my films i got
him writing because i told him that you
need more power
i want you to have your own power he's a
great writer so i got him writing then i
have one of my actors john torres i said
you have a good idea start writing
because i need writers so i got him
started writing so now he doesn't act as
a writer i got another writer leicester
ring that you know i got him right now
so whoever's around me i want to do more
i want to have more power i don't want
to be the only person to have all this
power i always say if you're in a room
and you're the only person with all the
money and your friends are looking for
you you're not doing a good job as a
leader i want everybody around me to
have power so if i need something i
could go to them if they need something
they come to me vice versa
how do you know they're good writers how
do you know they have what it takes to
make your vision alive oh yeah write it
and if i don't like it i don't use it
okay that makes sense okay
do you accept screenplays from other
screenwriters no
not not right now
everything everything is in-house
so it has to be your idea
right now okay
what if someone says i really want to
work with you i like your style
but this is my ip and i want it just
fine i'm if i like it i wouldn't like
some films i invest i invest in movies
other filmmakers so some filmmakers that
have the idea if i want to work with you
i just invested in film so some films i
invested because i want to help other
filmmakers
what should screenwriters know before
they start working with producers
copyright
copyright your ideas copyright
everything protect yourself that's the
first thing you do
once you get your idea copyrighted
because people will steal your idea
so copyright each first thing because
you know people
like
i've seen films that my one of my
friends wrote
and then they pitch it to the network
the network do the same idea we just
switch it up
so protect your stories
what about when people say no one's
doing that you know that's being
paranoid
i mean that's
it's up to you then figure that out but
i tell also writers don't just be a
writer start producing your own project
it don't make no sense to write a
hundred trips and you don't you're not
trying to produce your own stuff i think
like i said you can't be a one-trick
pony i would love just be a director but
i can't i gotta be a director producer
marketing mentor writing a book
because we in the age now there's so
much content coming out there you just
can't be a one-trick pony like i always
say if i was doing this back in the day
i'd be a millionaire
what are the biggest mistakes
screenwriters make when they reach out
to a producer you know copyright day
stuff
um
they do
well they don't copyright their stuff
and also
they spam people like don't just i get
emails sometimes people hit me up oh i
wanna here's a trip no no that's how
your stuff gets stolen
so don't be just saying yourself i just
send out don't do don't do that and then
you sit in like a complete film that's
different but if you send it no don't do
that and then try to produce your own
projects like stop waiting on a producer
stop waiting on me produce your own
project i started as a writer and i said
no one's what my story is i picture
small stories so do more for yourself
invest more on yourself people invest in
you
and you started with the short for for
lola but it wasn't called that right
mm-hmm it was decision split and it was
an eight minute short no like 20
something almost 30 minutes short oh
okay
do you have any advice for screenwriters
who are struggling to get people to read
their work
yes produce your own project
because what happens is like most people
don't have vision
so
it's okay to pitch your stuff that's
fine but take something you wrote
produce it
like
we got to stop thinking and i tell a lot
of stream writers that we got to stop
using that 1990 old mindset like if i
come in the room
and i'm a writer and all i have is trips
i did and you have filmmaker a that
wrote produce and doing their own stuff
i won't go with them because they really
want it they doing they're not waiting
for nobody so do more for yourself give
yourself the great chance as possible
because at the end of the day it's 100
stream writers we're going to make you
stand out and like i said sometimes it
does work but
why why wait like you could do your own
stuff stop stop get behind that computer
and get your hands dirty
so the 90s mindset is like over you're
just going to lunch you're trying to
find an investor that you know or a
producer that you're waiting for someone
to validate you
like you know it's filmmakers out there
that's better than me way better than me
but once again the house is so separate
you might be better than me but you're
not gonna hustle me
so if people say oh my films are better
than you you're probably right but guess
what i'm getting the meetings
i'm getting deals because i'm not
waiting for no one to deter my future
someone actually said that to you what
did that their films are better than
yours yeah and what contacts where were
you oh there's a film festival there was
like this film is my film is better why
are getting under awards
i know a lot he was right this one was
amazing
but the house is so separate his life
ain't fair house is so separate that's
where it is you're going to see
filmmakers that
you know win a whole bunch of wars or
like my film is better
that person did something
you you can't at the end of the day it's
only going to be something better than
you it might be a better project but
you have control of and there is what
you're going to do
so they confronted you in the lobby or
something wherever they told me face to
face
and i'll take and that's nothing don't
take that impersonal
a lot of people are really like this is
a business don't take nothing personal
no it's their opinion that's all his
opinion
and what was your answer to them
so that is the way it is right
they got the economy package of the
hustle yeah they got that yeah ubi east
package they got you got to like you
know and like i said life ain't fair
it's things i see like you go on netflix
right now like how do you get on netflix
they doing something like you you life
is not fear
i feel like sometimes i see things like
my movie's better back today it's not
about who's better it's who's hustling
more
what if a writer listening to this says
you know i don't i don't do the other
stuff i just write that's all i do and i
don't have the time money effort
whatever to go make this film myself
yes that's true you will have to find
someone that will help you
but just know that
it's two options in any world
if you're gonna wait for somebody
and people do other times oh you say no
way i'm tired of waiting let me try
something else got your comfort zone
because there's a hundred people that
sit there and write all day there's
nothing wrong with that you just gotta
know that you're gonna get what you put
out
like like me i was loved just to the
direct but i can't i got to do other
things because i know that we in a world
that is so much content coming out
and it's like keeping up with joneses so
it's up to you where you want your life
to be if you can't do something like you
know
for me i'm not a i'm not a great writer
i hire writers to work with me so you
got to figure out what you want to do
with your life you're going to wait
there behind that computer because
you're not it's it's a zillion people in
this world reach out to some independent
people go to film festivals like we all
have jobs and money back in the day to
make a movie almost was impossible now
it don't cost a lot of money
we gotta get we gotta we gotta put
ourselves in a better position and stop
doing the bare minimum and getting mad
that things are happening it's tough
love but i had to do that it was one
time i was like wow things ain't
happening to me i was doing a bad
minimal i wasn't doing enough so now i'm
like really aggressive because
like the internet is just so many
options we have to do what we need to do
so you have to ask yourself
you're going to wait
for that bus
or you're going to
get your hands dirty and hop on the bus
and go if you need to go is your choice
what is keeping up with the joneses in
filmmaking
people don't realize that
no one's waiting for you
you gotta you gotta keep up with
technology you gotta just keep it up and
upgrade yourself
like no one's really looking around like
i need a new writer like people writing
their own stories now people ain't
waiting for nobody so you want to
have that old mindset of i wait they're
going to come to me
you're a loss but i'm going to sit and
run laps
and keep running because you know it's
like i said
how's it all separate